hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of Hegel's key ideas that he is
discussing in the phenomenology and
developing in the self consciousness
section you have to do with the varied
nature of self consciousness and its
relation to desire and through desire to
another self consciousness we're not
going to explore all of that here we're
going to be focusing in this particular
video on sections 173 to 177 which lead
us up to what's famously called the
master-slave dialectic or dialectic of
lordship and bondage we'll talk about
that separately here we want to think
about the very nature of
self-consciousness itself before we go
into it and Hegel is going to tell us at
the beginning of this that
self-consciousness needs to attain a
kind of certainty of itself why does it
have to do that and it's foundation
self-consciousness is is not just
relational to its object but it makes
itself an object that is part of what it
means to be self conscious and this is
something we do all the time
whether we are conscious of it in a
explicit way or not we're always
implicitly conscious of it when I say oh
should I watch this video and I have
that I in there I am I'm you might say
exercising self-consciousness I'm asking
myself to make a choice about whether
it's worth my time or whether I should
be doing something else and and that
involves thinking about what it is that
I am and what the point of my activities
are there's all these other things and
fold it into it now we don't have to get
quite so concrete with this at the very
beginning he says self consciousness
attains certainty of itself only by
superseding and this is a translation of
a German term here that's very important
Hegel's work Alf Haven which is a verb
which means something like to transcend
but to bring along the essential
component along the way or to integrate
would be another way of thinking about
it when you integrate something within a
larger whole you
remove some of the independence of the
parts and you synthesized them into
something that has a greater type of
unity and probably more Dynamis 'ti as
well
so by superseding its object now what is
the object of self-consciousness you
could say that in a way it is just
itself but that doesn't turn out to be
the case for Hegel we don't have what we
call in philosophy a solipsism here
where I am the center of the universe
and everything else is merely figment of
my imagination or whatever it is I make
of them existing only in relation to me
no it is another a real other that is
going to provide the object for self
consciousness that doesn't mean that
we're not constantly engaged with a
world of objects that don't possess self
consciousness everything from books to
to pieces of chalk to our clothing items
to the lighting in this room whatever it
is else that you like and including
other animals that don't exhibit the
same structure of self-consciousness
that Hegel's talking about but we only
have the true meaning of our
self-consciousness and the full
potentiality of it when we exist in
relation to another and this is
something that self-consciousness is
whether it realizes it or not constantly
striving to do to figure out what it is
and what kind of being it is and how it
should be by integrating transcending
superseding it's its object so Hegel
goes on and tells us something really
key here about this this process in
telling us that this is the the nature
of self-consciousness as desire geared
in in German he says here we go
self-consciousness is desire certain of
the nothingness of this other it
explicitly affirmed that there's nothing
this is for it the truth of this other
now that sounds very abstract but if we
think about what that means when we have
desire for something like for
since I desire to read and understand
Hegel it presents itself to me as here's
just my my task or the object in front
of me the thing that that is confronting
me but I myself act upon it I myself
penetrate into it I make it my own
in doing so I remove its independence I
in a sense negate it I introduced the
[ __ ] the nothingness or the negation
that's involved within that thing and
now that's just an object although books
are interesting sort of objects
something mediate to us the thoughts of
another person if I say I truly want to
understand Hegel that means that for
Hegel in a certain sense
I want to assimilate I want to to
dominate I want to consume Hegel and
there's only a certain amount of mileage
that I can get out of this in terms of
treating objects that way so he goes on
he says by destroying the independent
object I give myself the certainty of
myself as a true certainty I integrate
truth and certainty together
a certainty which has become explicit
for self consciousness itself in an
objective manner and that's just a first
step
but now realizing this this this
function of desire within self
consciousness itself as integral to its
very nature is key Hegel goes on and
talks about why it is that we have to
focus upon objects that are like
ourselves
not just the world of objects that we
might come across again like pieces of
chalk these cannot provide me truly what
I want they're great for writing on the
board but they can't provide me what it
is that my desire is fundamentally for
so Hegel is opening up to us the nature
of what our deeper desires are desired
wants to consume the object it wants to
turn the object into the nothingness
that it is so I see the sandwich
I'm hungry I mean that's the literal
translation of the gear to hunger right
to the sandwich
oh it looks good I'm going to eat it all
up and then it's gone
nice well it's not going on dr. Sadler
it's been consumed it's in your belly
well that is algae Haven oklahoman
rather I have I have transmuted it into
bits of me and I'm going to work on it
myself with my organs and when we can
talk about this with other things you
buy a book because you want to master a
particular skill and you're going to
throw that book away when you're done
with it you've turned it into a lifeless
husk on it now you can cast aside now
what about people what about our
relations with human beings this is
where it gets particularly interesting
Hegel thinks that what we want is for
objects to negate themselves within
themselves we don't just want to
exercise our own agency on these objects
we want them to be for us to do for us
to make themselves for us and we also at
the same time need the object to be
independent because as soon as there's
you know as soon as the object has lost
its independence it's no longer quite as
interesting for us it no longer arouses
our desire no longer provides
satisfaction to the same extent so we
have something paradoxical here in
self-consciousness particularly self
because what self-consciousness is
desiring is another self-consciousness
Hegel Satele us that self-consciousness
attains its satisfaction lady goings in
German only in another
self-consciousness and here he brings in
a key term on air-cannon in German which
we translate as recognition in in most
cases or acknowledgment is another way
to put it and we're going to talk more
about that in other places about what
exactly what the nature of recognition
consists in but what Hegel is saying is
that fundamentally we are looking not
just for consuming objects the way
animals do but understanding ourselves
through being recognized
by others and that means also
understanding ourselves as being that do
in fact recognize others as others so
he's going to talk about this in terms
of self consciousness existing for
another self consciousness and this is
going to get us to the point of talking
about spirits or our Geist in German so
he says the self consciousness exists
for a self consciousness only so is it
in fact self consciousness for only in
this way does the unity of itself in its
other nests because it for us
Hegel says that we only truly know
ourselves in a matrix with other people
we cannot know ourselves and be certain
of what it is that we are and be
satisfied with ourselves without some
connection with the other they provide
us with a kind of necessary mediating
term so he goes on and he tells us that
you know the desire the object of desire
is only independent for it is the
universal indestructible essence we're
looking for something greater here and
this is going to lead him to talking
about spirit he has a beautiful little
passage at the end of this he's calling
this the notion that the gift of spirit
not the fullness of spirit and he says
what lies ahead for consciousness is the
experience of what spirit is this
absolute substance which is the unity of
the different independent self
consciousness as the idea is we are to
try to get to the point where each self
consciousness is able to obtain
recognition from the other self
consciousnesses and be independent
that's a very high order to try to meet
but it is possible indeed and that's
part of what he carries out there so we
end this by talking about here we go
independent self consciousness is which
in their opposition enjoy perfect
freedom and independence I that is we
and we that is I so he says that it is
in self consciousness that this whole
notion of spirit or mind in its fullest
sense
emerges for us in a very implicit form
that requires a lot of working out so
all of this leads us to see that
self-consciousness is inextricably tied
up with another self-consciousness
through desire and desire is
fundamentally for recognition
you